if you if you feel everyone's making 70k
and you're making 70k
why not share the equity company with
everybody why own 100 of it because
you're sitting there worth a couple
hundred million why not have them have a
few hundred thousand dollars of net
worth added to them
yeah so
it's because the
the the the shares
currently like we're not public like so
the shares aren't
you can't like go sell them you know
what i mean oh but you can give a
uh a stock options where the individual
can invest over a five year period and
there are a lot of people that work for
companies who are not public that give
shares that allows the individual to
build up their network because right now
your employees don't have a high net
worth you do so although you are being
very noble on the area of giving
everybody a seventy thousand dollar
salary i'm thinking if you're gonna go
that why not go fully and give everybody
a piece of the company so it's equally
shared with everyone especially because
if you do that
then that takes the case study again
remember i'm coming from a selfish place
because i want to see how this thing
works long term on the case study so if
you did
200 employees
get a half a percent and you put a five
year vessel period that they have to
stay there would you consider doing that
yeah absolutely i think it's a great
idea but i'll say i'm not sure that i'm
really able to
to connect with you or explain to you
like like what some of the danger and
downside would be to doing it but i
still think it it's a it's it's
something good that we need to consider
either way
yeah i said i think
but i think that it's so hard i think
i could be wrong but i think it's so
hard because we're so deep in the system
the economic system
it's so hard i think for somebody that's
like working at that deep level in the
system to understand a world divorced
from shareholder supremacy
and i think that i think that if you
could understand
like a
a world
other than shareholder supremacy i think
it would make
the way that you're thinking through and
analyzing an issue very different yeah
the only way i'm thinking about it is
i'm thinking about it in a way of
uh hey this is the amount of money that
came in why don't we take the money that
came to la district county and let's get
the money to do so if you have equity
you because you you're you're in a very
you're very well let me try to explain
it to you i i feel like i feel like
you're i feel like you really want to
understand so let me try really hard to
explain it to you i don't think i want
to understand let me explain to my
question i think you got to understand
my question here's my question my
question isn't like i run account we
don't think that way right so you're
saying how come you guys don't think the
way i think no and i'm like i don't
think the way you think i don't like the
way you think yeah so i don't know how
to answer the question then because what
i'm saying to you is if you're worth 200
million why don't you give equal amount
of shares to your employees so they also
i'm not worth 200 million say 100
million whatever i'm not worth a hundred
million i asked you earlier if you're
doing four and a half million ebitda
they pay you 20 to 40 percent that's
about 100 million dollar network
no it no it isn't
how is it not ok if a person wanted to
buy if i if i were to right now you're a
pretty transparent guy that's what made
you unique what made you unique is the
fact that you were willing to be
transparent you were very much about
my income's 1.1 yeah yeah i mean i would
love to explain it to you i don't know
if i'm going to be able to but i'll try
if you want i'm all ears tell us okay
so
currently the way the economy works
as i understand it
is
the the the most important thing that
drives the companies is this thing that
this guy milton friedman came up with
right shareholder value
and basically the companies are
currently run in general with what's
going to enhance the stock price at some
time horizon
and then the the there's something that
the compensation experts do called
alignment incentive alignment and
basically what they do is they take
those stock price targets
and
things that the corporation wants to
achieve like a higher stock price
and they set up incentives for the
executives and employees and stuff like
that
so that it creates what the what the
experts call alignment
between the shareholders
who are
kind of
set up as the pr primary beneficiary of
the of the scheme
and it creates a harmonious it purports
to create a harmonious relationship
between them and quote unquote
management or top executives
so that they'll be aligned so that the
executives when they have to make a
really tough decision
that's going to prop up the stock price
that incentive is designed to make sure
that the executives make the decision
that's good for the shareholders good
for the stock price
and the value the multiples that you
talked about are predicated on having a
management team
that and and a setup of a company that's
run in this matter
if you took the exact same metrics
but you told shareholders they can never
lay off employees ever
if you took the exact same metrics and
you told employees you can never
raise customer prices in a way that's an
unjustifiable money grab
if you told the investors they were no
longer allowed to do those things
and they wouldn't be able to expect any
type of liquidity event from the company
really ever but not on any specific time
horizon and they couldn't create it
then the value of those shares
would be depressed significantly and it
would basically create a situation where
it was a fraction the company would be
worth in that scenario a fraction of
what it's otherwise worth so in a world
in a world where we're planning
to
join this kind of scam
that everybody can see that i think you
may
you know you may be bought into a little
bit
if we if we decide that we're willing to
participate in that scam and just to
just to have the rubber meet the road
for you because i think this one will
really land with you i had a gentleman
come up to me who i've known for for
close to two decades been a mentor of
mine been a ceo of multiple successful
companies in our industry
and run multi multiple multi-billion
dollar companies in our industry and he
came up to me and said dan
i could come join gravity
or somebody like me
and i could turn this into a
multi-billion dollar company within a
few years
because if we unwound this and that you
know
like not doing layoffs in the pandemic
when our competitor toast used it as an
excuse to laugh 50 of their employees
when their value was going from five
billion to eight billion dollars
not doing a hundred dollar uh price
increase in the pandemic to small
businesses like our competitor heartland
that's owned by global payments a public
company these are the the playbooks and
the models in our industry and the value
that you're
putting out there
is
it is based on the idea that you're
going to play ball in this way and ob
was saying that and i was like you know
what i don't think the world needs
another billionaire and i don't even
know that the world needs like a whole
lot more like multi-millionaires out
there
i think what we need is a company that's
willing to stick up for what's right
stick stick up for these principles
and the way we run the organization
currently
when we get together and make decisions
is we do it as if shareholders don't
exist so we we consider shareholders at
zero when we're considering how to run
the company all of a sudden if we create
the type of incentive alignment that
somebody who's like a hardcore
capitalist like an unapologetic
unapologetic capitalist would
yeah would would would try to get us to
do
are we still going to run the company in
the same way after that right and the
answer to that is maybe not and i would
like to think that we're all such good
people
that we would turn away from the
opportunity to make more money to stick
up for what's right to stick up for our
values but currently we just do it by
basically taking all of that money
and and basically
considering it to be money that's really
most rightfully you know uh considered
uh as an asset for clients small
businesses employees how can we use
these resources to help
and all of a sudden if we created that
kind of incentive alignment structure it
would it would really take us and make
us less of what we are and more of what
companies that you're used to seeing
[Music]